hello before this video begins I wanted
to remind you guys to check out Origin
PC comm slash PewDiePie first link in
the description sign up to the giveaway
cuz I'm giving away a computer by origin
it's an incredible piece of machinery
it's been kissed by yours truly
not gonna prove that it's filled with
love check out my setup video as well
where I show off my origin piece of
computer I love this thing I couldn't
recommend that enough and I'm very proud
to be working with origin but that's it
enjoy the video ma'am what what okay
well don't worry about it I can do the
same god damn it whoa this is dope
you got fireworks oh my god
oh that is bright yes yes have you seen
the m8 fades okay no okay let's let's go
I'm you are a ruther great I am I am
YouTube blogger - why what's your
channel ok ok Arvest i'll check you out
where the hell did he go come with me
come with me and I will show you all
right it's inside me
the way is inside me no I don't like
that okay go away from me hey hey my
boat is with food a food I'm not you
were right holy [ __ ] I can control it
alright what color do you guys want I
got this
that's all I know
no no no Uganda Hey look at you I'm one
of them I woke you I know you want to
die
Familia suka black silk yep whoa
only cat what is that oh my god don't
shoot don't shoot
I am Ugandan please don't shoot please
don't shoot
[Music]
stop spinning on everything hey hey hey
can I go with you
can I ride with you hey does anyone want
to touch them touch my nipples I'll take
you to my dungeon sound like it's about
the climax amazing Wow I am the queen
everybody you are welcome oh no no no no
don't spit don't spend no spitting I
will touch that stop spitting I will
bless each one of you come for Queen yes
I will banana man iw thank you man I dub
you Ugandan warrior that's right come on
are you coming say tomato I will bless
you I will bless you with my hands
come here tie-dye listen to me come here
and ever bless you heard it huh they are
mean so before that when they are cut up
and they ass up
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow you spin so graciously hey careful
with those blades you could cut someone
is that Mario something went wrong when
they made this the game wasn't supposed
to be like this huh god damn I look dead
oh my god knuckles made out of knuckles
this no I am thick thank you I am one
knuckles and the other knuckles are just
my dead children also where's your
second eye in your main thing I am just
don't worry about the details okay this
is just how I was born
this is who I am and please don't judge
listen you're like an undead creature
all right I don't need your judgment
from now on knuckles is running the bar
what can I get you get me every drink
every drink coming right up sir they we
got this one here we got this one we got
this one I hope you're ready to pay up I
know everything you need to know about
drinks that's right thank you
all right what do you want what do you
want this you can be my
stop poking me stop poking me
[Music]
listen I'm blocking left and right what
up
okay okay no he's not stop following me
please no no no it's Ugandan warrior all
right what do you want
please behind the counter people I'm my
god what happened to you then you need a
winna Keith very much love
oh all right I'm gonna go find the way
but it's been great can't wait to find
the way hey baby
you come erupting what is that come up
you want to say hi to Auntie Nikki will
you be my TV alright alright alright how
about how about this one
why does sonic wear gloves anyone
because his hands are cold okay
if tails lost one of his tails where
will he get a new one
your motors at the retailer thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
okay that was it for today's episode 15
emojis even if you didn't see you next
time